and i'll first just briefly describe
some of the other things i'm interested
in and how this fits in
so a lot of what i worked on is
called at least i call it exact
asymptotics which
refers
to
using amp theory or gaussian comparison
inequalities to derive very precise
predictions
for the area for the error of various uh
high dimensional regression
estimators
and this
exact asymptotics has a large list of
applications i've highlighted and read
the
uh sorts of things that i've worked on
in exact asymptotics
in this talk i'm going to tell you about
the debian application but the list is
long
next week at the conference i'm going to
talk about
designing first order methods
and in blue i've listed some things that
other authors have done that i haven't
worked on myself but which i would
certainly be
excited to learn more about and talk to
people about uh at this workshop so
um
okay so i'm gonna now just tell you
about this one application which is
correlation adjusted de-biasing so we
have a linear model
we have
is there a pointer maybe
yes
so we have an outcome variable y we have
p features which i put in this design
matrix x we have one feature which i've
put in this vector w
mathematically there's no difference
between w and x i've just given w a
different name
because in this talk i'm going to be
interested in estimating the particular
coordinate of the unknown parameter
vector which corresponds to the
covariate w so this is just reflective
of my interest as a
statistician and
i'm going to try to consistently
estimate beta in a proportional
asymptotic so n and p are going to go to
infinity their aspect ratio is going to
converge to a non-trivial constant
and i'll make a random design assumption
which is that the covariates are jointly
gaussian
and i'm going to introduce some new
notation so there's no new assumptions
here i'm just going to regress
the sort of special feature w on the
remaining features x
because things are jointly gaussian
that satisfies a linear model with
linear model parameter gamma which is
going to play a large role in what i
tell you about
and this i'll call the
covariate model parameter and theta i'll
call the outcome model parameter
okay so uh the first thing that you
might think to do is to use the lasso
uh so we're going to estimate
both beta and theta the full unknown
parameter vector using the lasso and
then just extract the
coordinate beta from that estimate
and this does quite badly so in this
simulation i'm choosing the outcome
model and covariate model parameters in
a particular way
they're sort of the signal strength is
denoted by mu and the sparsity is
denoted by s and on the x-axis i've
plotted the signal strength
and you see that for very strong signals
uh and very sort of denser vectors so
here about 20 of the coordinates are
non-zero we get a very large bias
in the estimate of beta so the dotted
line shows you the true value of beta
and okay there's a substantial
degradation in the performance of the
lasso for estimating the single
coordinate when you have very complex
strong signals and indeed uh
you can show though i don't actually
know a theorem that states this but it's
it's pretty easy to show and i think
it's sort of implicit in a lot of
analyses
that the s theorem error in estimation
beta error in estimating beta can be as
large as sigma square root of s log p
over s over n which in a proportional
asymptotics is order one
so one thing that's been proposed to
improve the estimate of beta is to add a
correction term so this is called the d
bias lasso and this correction term is
complicated to understand but
you'll note that it depends upon the
sort of covariate model parameter so it
requires oracle knowledge of of the
covariant model
and it does well so here i've done the
same simulation and at least in this
simulation appears to have
eliminated the bias across signal
strengths and complexity
levels of the unknown parameter
and there's actually quite a lot of
theory about this d bias lasso so i'll
just give you some results
so what pure bellick and chun wuzeng
showed was that not only do we get
consistency we get asymptotic normality
and we get consistency at a root end
rate and they need some assumptions so
they need either that the lasso was
consistent to begin with
or that the sample size is larger than
the dimensionality though need not be
you know dramatically larger than the
dimensionality
and then myself andrea montenera and
utengue showed that you know this result
is true in a sense on average across the
coordinates so this is sort of an
empirical distribution of the difference
between the d biased estimate and the
true parameter appropriately
renormalized
uh and uh okay so under proportional
asymptotics and first efficiently sparse
theta uh you get asymptotically
uh you get that the d bias lasso
estimate is asymptotically normal
so the focus of of of the work i'm
telling you about today is looking at a
situation where we don't know this
covariate model parameter
and before i tell you our result let me
just try to show you some results that
indicate that maybe this uh
problem is hard that the problem of
estimating beta consistency when you
don't consistently when you don't know
gamma is difficult
uh so this is a minimax lower bound of
uh tony kai and zijiang guo which was
refined by adele javon martin andre
montanari
and the minimax lower bound for
estimating beta that they get is one
over root n which goes to zero into
proportional asymptotics and then the
minimum of the sparsity of theta and
gamma log p over n so this term will not
go to zero in a proportional asymptotics
which suggests that maybe consistency is
not possible now the catch is that
they first make an assumption which
eliminates uh the proportional regime so
they require a sparsity that's sub
linear in the dimensionality but okay
when these results float around you
maybe think that a
consistent estimation of beta is is hard
in a proportional regime and as far as i
know before our work under proportional
asymptotics
there are no sort of successful
demonstrations of consistently
estimating beta when you don't know
gamma in a proportional regime
uh and
okay in the interest of time maybe i'll
skip the second point well no i won't
okay so the
you know
um if you look at this if you know the
lasso literature then you'll then this
term goes to zero when uh
you can consistently estimate either
theta or gamma in l2 norm okay so what
you might think is that in order to
estimate beta consistently you need to
sort of estimate one of the nuisance
parameters consistently and there's a
sort of large literature on double
robustness and which is this is exactly
sort of what happens that you sort of
always get consistent estimation of a
low dimensional parameter when you can
sort of either consistently estimate the
outcome model theta or the
covariant model gamma well and you know
the sort of regime where you can either
estimate either consistently is much
less study
so what we do is we
show how to consistently estimate beta
in at least some settings in which you
can either estimate theta or gamma
consistently
and one of the settings which i'll just
tell you about in this talk though there
are others in our paper is a
semi-supervised setting in which we have
access to some additional unlabeled
samples with which we can estimate gamma
we don't have so many unlabeled samples
that we can estimate gamma consistently
but we have sort of more samples than
the dimensionality of gamma so that we
can estimate
gamma with ols and get an unbiased
estimate and somehow this unbiased
estimate even though it's not consistent
will allow us to uh consistently
estimate beta
this is our estimator uh
there's no reason to unpack it it's not
that
meaningful to me either
but this is it
and our theorem states that okay in a
proportional asymptotics
if you have some sort of bounded
singular values on the
covariance of the
covariates x
and theta is sufficiently sparse though
it can be proportionally sparse then you
get that this sort of cad estimate or
correlation adjusted de-biasing estimate
is consistent for beta
okay and we also look at other settings
which i've noted down here but i don't
have time to tell you about right now
okay and so now i've done the same
simulation with this cad estimate
we have no sort of oracle knowledge of
gamma that's being plugged into it we
don't consistently estimate gamma we
don't consistently estimate data
and okay i'm only showing you the bias
but okay something good has happened
we've eliminated
the covariance of the news and features
in this plot is the identity i believe
but gamma's non-zero so there's sort of
correlations between the
special covariate and the others
okay so uh
what does this have to do with exact
asymptotics so i'll just sort of
advertise that here i'm not going to
really explain it very well it turns out
that analyzing this problem and this cat
estimator involves or can be reduced to
studying sort of the joint behavior of
two simultaneous regression estimates
from two sort of linear models that are
coupled together
so here i'm going to i have sort of two
outcome variables y2 and y1 both of
which are generated from some distinct
linear model using the same covariates x
i'm going to estimate them
simultaneously using the same data
and what sort of a standard exact
asymptotics would give you with some
marginal results so for example you
might be able to get a very precise
prediction about what the limiting value
of the
norm of the residuals is or what the
limiting l2 estimation error is
and what we need in this paper and one
of the tools that we develop is sort of
a joint exact asymptotics which allows
you to also
get at the joint behavior of two
different estimators from coupled linear
models
so these are sort of uh quantities which
are not
accessible from
standard exact asymptotic or existing
exact asymptotic results the only paper
i know of prior to ours which looked at
some sort of joint exact asymptotics was
this one by
mondeli trompolidus and vengataramanan
and
anyway this is really just an
advertisement so if anyone wants to hear
more about this then
i'd be interested in talking to you
and that's that's it
[Applause]
well thanks michael um
so yeah if there are any quick questions
you're welcome to ask them
uh right now or you can wait 30 seconds
outside so to you
um
one second all right so so yeah so my
understanding from the schedule on the
website is that there's some sort of
perception about
what's happening is that how's
yeah i imagine it's just outside and
a big thanks to all of the fellows